les sirènes d'ambulances sont devenus la
trame sonore de cette troisième vague à
johannesbourg
les sud africains sont à nouveau confiné
depuis un mois les hôpitaux débordent
il manque cruellement d'oxygène on
manque aussi de lits et de personnel
sous payés et épuisé après 18 mois au
front de la pandémie
70000 sud africains sont morts de la
coved ses 42 % des décès de tout le
continent
cela s'expliquerait par la grande
mobilité de la population qui est aussi
la plus âgée du continent donc la plus
vulnérable au virus des soins déficiente
aussi provoqué des décès évitables et
fait fuir les malades et ou inscrit
c'était des parents 17 militants de
soweto qui a une à coville en janvier
dernier oxygène de pipe au bec
la situation est préoccupante ce médecin
canadien d'origine guinéenne enseigne à
l'école de santé publique de
l'université de montréal il y à 18 mois
il a pris congé de son poste pour aller
au front de l'aco vide en algérie au
mozambique en république démocratique du
congo
il a vu les hôpitaux atteindre le point
de rupture
attention important sur la prise en
charge des cas sévères et des cas
critiques djokovic 19 et qu'il nécessite
évidemment l'administration donne de
l'oxygène à louer baisse affirme que
dans les six pays africains les plus
touchés 73 % des malades de l'aco vide
qui ont besoin d'oxygène non pas
le maroc et la tunisie sont aussi
frappés de plein fouet
c'est infirmiers dit n'avoir jamais vu
pire maladie chez lui de fausses c'est
le plus grave du tout du mal à diriger
juge qu'on est contre la récupération et
reload entendent hui dans trois heures
et appelé d'oxygène on reste comme ça on
a débouté relais beauté un peu partout
donc ça fait ça stresse vous imaginez si
jamais on appelait d'oxygène ça c'est
terrible
les vaccins sont distribuées au compte
gouttes
moins de trois pour cent des africains
ont reçu une première dose en tunisie
l'ouverture de 29 centres de vaccination
sans rendez vous mardi a provoqué cohue
et bousculades
si vous vacciner et moi je me vaccine
réseau s'est pacsé la contamination
s'est réduit
ce sera comment s'appellera pas déjà
plus besoin de lancer son réacteur
le problème c'est que c'est c'est manque
rapidement de vaccins qui arrive souvent
trop tard en afrique
il expire avant d'arriver à destination
ces derniers mois près de deux millions
de doses expiré ont dû être détruites
en plus d'avoir les personnes donc il
faut nous ayons aussi les moyens pour
pouvoir donc distribuer ces vaccins
l'âge
cette flambée de covile survie en plein
tabaski ou l'aïd la plus importante fête
musulmane celle du mouton
au sénégal on recommande d'éviter les
prières collectives et les
rassemblements mais ils ne sont pas
interdits nous remercions dieu dit il
nous sommes musulmans
on n'a pas seulement de dieu on ne
craint pas le virus
seulement 6% des sénégalais ont reçu une
première dose du vaccin parce qu'il en
manque et parce qu on hésite à se faire
vacciner
le sénégal a reçu de l'europe 300
millions de dollars pour construire une
usine qui fabriquera des vaccins antique
vide 300 millions de doses par année je
pense que la confiance dans le fait que
les gens maxime beaucoup plus quand ils
500 l'accent qui est localement
l'afrique ne produit que 1 % des vaccins
nécessaires à ses habitants la pandémie
de coved a révélé les effets
dévastateurs de cette dépendance le
continent souhaite d'ici 2040 produire
60 % des vaccins administrés aux
africains